all righty it is time to get started on
the responsive blog project you can find
a link to a zip file with the project in
it in the downloadable section note that
the zip file is pretty large because of
all the images inside it so this is what
the blog looks like right now and you
should be asking yourself Oh what the
heck is this ugly thing the good news is
that by the end of the course you'll be
turning in it to something that looks a
little bit like this which is definitely
a lot nicer now responsive images can be
as much of an art as it is a science the
way you make your images responsive will
totally depend on how you want to use
them in your site's when all is said and
done your blog may look very different
than this but that doesn't make it any
less correct it's up to you to decide
how you want to beautify this blog and
make its images responsive to start
working on this project which is really
zoomed out here by the way I'm gonna
give you a few changes some will be
mandatory and some will be optional your
goal is to make these images look sane
right now they're massive both in their
visual size on the page and this is
zoomed out to 25% here so they're really
really big and they're also big in the
number of bytes that they include in
that they're just simply way too large
back at 100% it's pretty clear these
images aren't fitting inside their
containers the images and the website
needs some kind of width applied to them
so that they stay inside their container
which in this case is an article once
you've done that set a maximum width on
the article element to give the blog a
little bit better structure I recommend
starting with the width of something
around 50 MS remember in M refers to the
font size so a 50 M element with font
sizes of 16 pixels means that we're
talking about a width of 800 pixels by
the way notice how these images are
coming from images source we'll come
back to that in a second next up check
out this volt you see how it's natural
width is almost 30 300 pixels that's
just massive what's the point of so many
pixels when it's going to be displayed
at about 800 pixels wide
even on a 2x display you only need 1600
pixels across so there are so many
wasted bytes here these images
need to be a lot smaller I want you to
use the tools and techniques that you've
been learning to reduce the resolutions
and compress the images see how low you
can get the resolutions and how much
compression you can use while still
keeping really crisp images to do so
you've got grunt image magic and image
optimal your side and you definitely
don't have to use these but it'll make
your life a lot easier if you do
especially grunt if you've got grunt up
and running you should be able to use
the grunt file in the project directory
after you run the command in the
instructor notes the command will make
sure that the grunt responsive images
package is installed notice that grunt
is going to run against images in the
images source directory and put them in
the images directory right now in the
HTML all of the images can be found in
the images source directory but once
you've optimized them make sure you
change their directory to images there
are links to lots of documentation in
the instructor notes if you need help
right now the page is coming in around
3.1 megabytes which will take forever to
load on mobile seriously try loading the
site using the network throttling option
set to 3G you may want to grab a cup of
coffee while you wait a few minutes for
the page to load
you can probably reasonably drop the
total bytes from the images below 1.5
megabytes or even further in terms of
optional changes the images are looking
pretty lonely right now they need some
captions so add some in the solution
video you'll see me add some captions
using the semantic figure tag but you
can use whatever technique you'd like
see the instructor notes for more
documentation on figure so to summarize
first things first make sure the images
fit within their containers then once
you've done that make the containers a
reasonable width and I recommend about
50m once the images are actually being
displayed properly it's time to resize
and compress them they should stay sharp
but the page should drop below 1.5
megabytes total in fact I'd be willing
to bet you can do even better than 1.5
megabytes make sure you use automation
tools otherwise your life is going to be
much more difficult than it needs to be
but to be fair it can be difficult
installing grunt so make sure you use
the instructor notes and as an optional
challenge add some captions of course
make sure you're testing on different
devices and network settings and once
you've done the first second and third
parts of this challenge a code will
appear on the screen type that code in
here to continue